you know what these endless Democrat
attacks and the president remind me of
[Music]
yeah they think they have him on the
cliff they'll think they'll get him on
the move but it always ends up the same
way
[Music]
[Music]
is that Andrew McCabe I can tell well
still the Democrats continue to resort
to the same failed tactics against this
president they spent thirty two million
dollars chasing the fantasy of Russian
collusion and along the way they
celebrated a string of buffoons kind of
cartoon characters in and of themselves
they imagine these people would once and
for all
slay Trump first there were the two
Michaels I believe that ultimately he
will be forced to resign due to
information that his is going to come to
light in connection with our case this
do right here I think of him as in a
Justice League with robert muller to
save our democracy
this behavior is churlish it denigrates
the office of the president and it's
simply on american people are gonna
start flipping i think that trump never
thought would flip before this is where
it ends for this president i love the
way it's dramatic then there was muller
the messiah can you repeat the question
sir could you repeat that place i leave
it with the report can you repeat the
last part of that question when Law and
Order Special Counsel edition was
cancelled
well they reverted to the old standard
you're a racist is the president a white
supremacist yes he's also made that very
clear that president's actions and words
have conveyed a very strong sense to
many many Americans that he has white
supremacist beliefs and he is not only
egging on white supremacy and white
nationalism but he is one himself what
more do we need to see you hear from
this racist man and all the while they
challenged Trump's every policy in
federal court and activist judges issued
nationwide injunction stymieing elements
of the President's agenda ish and white
injunctions undermine the democratic
process depart from our history and
tradition violate constitutional
principles and impede sound judicial
administration all at the cost of public
confidence in our institutions here here
and this week the Democrats are back to
square one
banking on another disgruntled insider
to take down Trump a whistleblower
reportedly claims that Trump made a
promise to a foreign leader tonight the
New York Times in the Washington Post
say that this involves the country of
Ukraine now we barely know any of the
facts yet but the left is already
assuming the worst it just gives me
chills to hear you say that I mean if
you think about this whistleblower
they've got something that's incredibly
sensitive it's astonishing I've never
heard of anything like this
and it should be deeply troubling to
Americans this does rise to a much
higher level of concern because I think
this could be something closer to
betrayal deja vu come on come on
Democrats don't really care about
whistleblowers does anyone remember what
the Obama administration's attitude was
toward lists whistleblowers the liberal
Guardian newspaper characterized it this
way Obama's war on whistleblowers leaves
administration insiders unscathed and
the American media responded with a
collective yarn to all of that but boy
they're all about the whistleblower
tonight they need something anything to
avoid talking about Trump's actual
record the US economy is the envy of the
world as Europe and Asia slides ever
toward recession let's look at the new
OECD projected GDP numbers for 2019
shall we the u.s. is at 2.4 percent GDP
projection Japan 1% Germany 0.5% Italy
down to zero and they're more at the
bottom of the barrel well we're doing
better than any g7 country and the
Americans know what we feel it Trump's
approval ratings spiked 4 points to 43%
last month his approval among
Republicans is at 91% that's a
phenomenal accomplishment imagine where
his overall approval numbers would be if
we had a press that was even minimally
objective not all the time but let's say
30 percent of the time but the Democrats
believe that they can win the White
housed through a combination of
demonization and investigation I say let
them have at it
if Trump keeps racking up results for
the American people the Democrats will
come up empty-handed
once again
[Music]
next time we'll get him that's the angle